hello everyone I've got lots of
questions here and so welcome to the
first live question-and-answer YouTube
session that I'm hosting so I'm going to
get right into it and answer some
questions there's lots coming up on the
screen here Mac one three five seven one
nine seven nine asks what does it mean
people don't have ideas ideas have
people are we okay because I've got an
error here sorry about that we're gonna
you're going to hear some technical talk
during this because we don't exactly
know what we're doing yet okay so what
does it mean people don't have ideas
ideas have people I learned that mostly
from young in fact I think that's
virtually a direct quote from from Carl
Jung one of the things I learned from
yiling was that it's perfectly
reasonable to think of ideas as
something that's living as something
that's a that's a lie but an idea is
something that's alive and I think the
reason for that is that the beans that
have ideas and so that's us people are
alive and we're trying to use our
cognitive ability to further our living
and so we create ideas that and and the
purpose of those ideas is to have them
played out in embodiment to have them
act out acted out because otherwise
they're not of any utility and so the
conjure up ideas let's say originally
but they take on life of their own over
time and as they take on a life of their
own their capacity to dominate someone
increases to the point where the idea is
arguably more powerful than the person
know so if you look at religious ideas
for example maybe you could think of
what happened with regards to Islam and
not you know end up in the latter part
of the first Christian millennium a set
of ideas exploded out of one source and
and swept through a vast population the
same thing happened with Christianity
and said in fact the same thing is
happening with Christianity right now in
China China in China Christianity is
spreading faster than it did in the
Roman times and that's not something we
really notice because our time frame is
you know small compared to thousands and
thousands of years but
ideas have their own goal and their own
perception and their own way of
interacting with the world and it's it's
always possible for them to possess
people
why do we feel exposed and vulnerable
when we know and do what we really like
your words that sell H
well
lots of times people hide behind a shell
even at cost to them because if the
shell gets criticized then it's not
really that relevant because it doesn't
have any direct bearing on them and so
if you're not showing your true self so
to speak to the world and what you're
showing is something essentially that's
false are just constructed and that gets
criticized well you can always comfort
yourself with the idea that it's not
really you that's under attack so it
doesn't wound to the same degree now and
I mean that's partly why people protect
themselves with falsehoods and
ideologies and and it's an attempt to
shield their genuine vulnerability from
assault by the world but the problem is
is that if you don't allow that
vulnerability to manifest itself then
the probability that you're actually
ever going to get what you really like
or even discover what it is is zero so
by protecting yourself to that degree
you end up losing certainly losing it
what it is that you're most trying to
protect I mean I don't want to be
cavalier about top because it's
understandable that people attempt to
shield their vulnerability because the
vulnerability isn't just felt it's real
and people are fragile and you know
we're subject to the terrible forces of
nature and to the terrible forces of
culture so
we put all sorts of masks in front of
ourselves so that our exposures limited
people even do that to themselves to
some degree if your front is false
enough then it it's also false to you
and I suppose people do that to some
degree to protect themselves against
their own self criticisms
David guida says how could high school
teachers best promote virtue cultivate
morality and tackle the meaning crisis
in the face of an increasingly chaotic
violent and dehumanized teacher well I
would say it isn't obvious to me that
the future is increasingly chaotic
violent and dehumanized that the past
was pretty rough now the future is
definitely ill-defined we don't know
what's going to happen and I think maybe
that's more true in a general sense than
it ever has been in the history of
mankind but I don't necessarily think
that there's reasons to be particularly
pessimistic however the first part of
the question I think is is well worth
addressing how can high school teachers
best promote virtue cultivate cultivate
morality and tackle demeaning crisis
well I think the best way that people in
general promote virtue and cultivate
morality is by promoting virtue and
cultivating morality within their own
life but I think that in order to do
that for yourself and then also in order
to transmit that information to your
students you have to understand that
morality isn't a set of injunctions of
the nature of don't ever do anything
impulsive that you like which is
generally how morality is put forth you
know what you think about morality is
something that a puritanical person
might preach and that it has to do
mostly with self control and self
constraint I I think that that's a very
shallow
that's a very shell shallow vision of
morality I think the way that you
convince people to act morally if that's
something that you're interested in
doing is to meditate on the utility of
the truth because I think the highest
form of morality is following the truth
so you might say well why would you
bother following what's true and the
answer that I think is quite
straightforward if you follow what's
false then you're going to end up
somewhere that you weren't planning to
go and the probability that that's going
to be good is low I mean following
what's false is like attempting to use
the wrong map for for for the territory
that you occupy and if your eyes are
open and you pay attention then the
probability that you'll be able to
maneuver around the terrible sharp
obstacles that will emerge in front of
you is that much higher and so when
you're having a serious discussion about
morality with people there's a there's a
couple of points that you make to begin
with is like and these are fundamental
points one would be do you want things
to be better or do you want things to be
worse and
you might assume that people are going
to automatically answer that they'd
rather have things better but that's not
so self-evident because to make things
better usually requires that you adopt a
tremendous amount of responsibility and
that's effortful and difficult and
frightening and the buck sort of stops
with you which is also part of what
makes it terrifying but if you do want
things to be better and you have your
mind straight and oriented in that
direction then the truth is your best
possible guide because it'll help you
get to that point so I think one of the
things that people who talk about
morality fail to understand is that it's
not abstract it's practical morality is
precisely what's proved to be most
practical over the longest possible span
of time sort of like the moral act is
what's best all things considered and
part of the reason that it's necessary
for people to follow conventional rules
is because convention is part of the
wisdom of mankind and the wisdom of
mankind has basically said no all things
considered here's a pathway that you can
follow that is going to work out in
principle best for you and so you you
know one of the one of the
considerations they're speaking in terms
of convention is you know the standard
path through life say in Western culture
has been to grow up to form an intimate
relationship of some stability to do
something productive that other people
approve of and and and will trade with
you for to raise children and to
establish yourself in a community and
the reason that that's conventional
morality is because that's not such a
bad deal compared to most of the
alternatives and if you can pull all
those things off properly then
there's a reasonable chance that you'll
at least have a life that isn't
completely full of unbearable suffering
with nothing positive in it but there's
also the pole there's also a reasonable
possibility that you'll have a good life
and so then you might want to try to do
that correctly why act morally why are
in a virtuous Manor because it's in your
interest and it's in everyone's in else
everyone else's interest as well and so
that seems like a good deal now it will
mean that you'll have to put off certain
forms of impulsive pleasure
but the problem often with impulsive
pleasure is that while you you have
pleasure at haste and you repent at
leisure and so part of what standard
morality is trying to do is to inform
you about how you might act in the
present so that the present is
acceptable but so the tomorrow is also
good and next week is also good and next
month is also good and and next year is
also good and for you and for your
family and for your community for this
broad swath of humanity and partly what
you ask people you ask high school
students is well they want to be part of
that or do they want to do something
else and if they want to do something
else maybe they want to make things
worse well they should think that
through because that's just not a very
good plan you know unless your goal is
to make the world a more miserable place
and you know often people's goals are
precisely that
Alex beyond duress is mindfulness really
beneficial or is it just a trend mam
mostly it's a trend
the problem with mindfulness as far as
I'm concerned is that it's is and so
it's a word that's like a giant box you
can put anything you want in it and
claim that that's not only what it is
but that's what it does
and so I I'm you know I would be very
hesitant to make a blanket statement
such you know like no one practicing
mindfulness or teaching mindfulness is
producing any benefit for their students
but yeah I think mostly it's a it's a
fad so
how can Disney produce an archetypal
masterpiece in the mid-90s Lion King and
then turn around and create propaganda
in the new millennium frozen that's why
Sam Collett god that's a good question
but there's an even better question that
goes along with it it's like not only
could did Disney turn around and create
propaganda in the new millennium because
I do believe exactly that that's what
frozen is but if I remember correctly I
think that that's the highest-grossing
animated movie now that's ever been made
so it's not only that they created
properly on it it's that people are
extraordinarily hungry for it
why would that be well one of the
ideological motifs in frozen is that you
know the classic idea that the Sleeping
Beauty needs a prince to awaken her is
absurd an old fashion and that there are
alternative ways of traveling through
life that don't require the subjugation
that that particular story might appear
to entail I think that's really naive
beyond belief because a story like
Sleeping Beauty where the feminine is
waiting for the masculine to awaken
it's true it's just as true for men as
it is for women it's not about men and
women precisely it is to some degree
it's more about the masculine and the
feminine the feminine part of a man
which is the part that enables him to
have a relationship with a woman at all
is awoken by the archetypal masculine
qualities of clarity of mind for example
just as much as the females femininity
is awoken by masculine clarity of mind
and you can read those stories in
sleeping beauty and all likelihood it's
a variable story at multiple levels
simultaneously so but I think that
people want the propaganda because it
tells them that what they already think
is correct and that all the old wisdom
are much of the old wisdom it can just
be dispensed with in people can
conductor lies in any manner that they
want well that doesn't work so
Julian Tian says you have said that the
study history is to study oneself and
that one will be much more grounded and
strong if they do so we please more talk
on this please talk more on this
well you know it's easy for people to
think let's say you're 30 years old it's
easy for you to think that you're
actually 30 years old but you're not
you're in many ways in at least in one
level of analysis you're three and a
half billion years old because that's
approximately how long the genetic
structure that has given rise to you at
least in part has existed and you're the
consequence of this massive massively
extensive evolutionary process extending
back billions of years
that's conditioned every aspect of you
and so you're a very very ancient
creature from a biological perspective
and if you don't view yourself across
that entire span of time so to speak you
have the wrong idea about what it means
to be a human being and then on the
cultural end of things while you're
deeply shaped and and inhibited and
offered opportunity by the entire
history of human cultural endeavor which
is also interactive in the causal manner
with with the emergence of our biology
across time and if you don't understand
history then you don't understand who
you are because you're a product of
history everything you think someone
else already thought every word that you
use someone else came up with and so
and naive person thinks for example that
the thoughts that they have are their
thoughts but the probability that you're
going to have a thought that's original
is extraordinarily low and so just to
understand your own thought process you
need to be deeply you understand your
own thought process far more deeply if
you're an astute student of history you
also understand the problems that
confront you in the world I mean you're
born into the world in a particular
historical configuration that's an
archetypal truth you know your spirit is
born into the world when the world is a
certain specific way and that certain
specific way is also a consequence of
vast patterns of processes that have
laid themselves out on a historical
timeframe I mean just a simple example I
mean a lot of the interpersonal
complexities that young people face
saying they're in their intimate
relationships are direct consequence of
the birth control pill I mean absolutely
being around for 50 years so it's not
deep history but it's certainly it's
certainly history and if you don't
understand that the birth control burst
in on humanity like an app like an
atomic bomb
maybe like a hydrogen bomb you don't
understand what it is that's driving
your own interpersonal problems so
there's no difference between studying
history and studying psychology and
there's there's no difference between
studying history and psychology and
trying to understand who you are and
what you should do histories about you
it's not about the world or it's about
the world and you and like
if you can't see the sense in it then
you're not approaching it properly or
you have bad teachers or you don't know
how to read or something like that
because history is unbearably
interesting and so I suppose that's
another marker that you can use to
determine whether or not your attitude
towards studying history is correct if
you're not fascinated and horrified by
an almost beyond belief
then you're not studying history
properly and I think if you were
studying it properly
you'd never ask why you should study it
it would be so evident so obvious that
it was necessary
why did humans enjoy sad stories that's
elux Beyonder
well I don't know if they actually
enjoyed them although I think you can
make a case that they do mean sometimes
maybe someone's watching a story that's
that's somewhat sentimental that'll make
them tear up and you might say that
that's an element of being sad but I
would say that's more an element of
being compassionate and participating in
this fictional way in in the love and
the and intimacy that human beings are
capable of so you can do that by proxy
and that can certainly produce
sentimental emotions and nostalgic
emotions and those can be associated
with tears but you could go deeper than
that and say well people will watch
tragic stories but not certainly the
case in any Shakespearean play virtually
is is tragic in many regards and I think
part of the reason that people are are
compelled to do that is because we're
compelled to understand the tragedies of
our life and so to see that tragedy laid
out on a stage which means that it's
distilled and amplified in some sense is
to simultaneously engage in the problem
of wrestling with what it means to exist
in a tragic world and any information
you can get about that is going to be
well worth the momentary negative
emotion that you might experience while
you're engaged in the play so people
like sin stories because life is often
sad and we have to figure out how to
deal with them then stories can tell you
how to deal with it well and how to deal
with it badly and that can be absurdly
informative
if Christianity has much historical
wisdom to offer why is it so derided in
the Academy is this a good thing or a
bad thing why Brian Ross
I think that people generally think of
Christianity as science for stupid
people it's something like that you know
what it's often reduced to it's more
fundamentalist manifestations so you
know that the straw man version of
Christianity is fundamentalist
Protestantism of the sort that makes the
case that the Bible is literally true
and that the cosmos is roughly several
thousand years old well it's easy to
it's easy to make fun of that I'm not
sure so why is to make fun of it keeping
people generally have reasons for what
they believe and sometimes it's fear and
narrow-mindedness and ignorance but
sometimes what might appear to be fear
and fear and narrow mindedness and
ignorance is actually the attempt to
preserve something of extraordinary
extraordinary value the value of which
has not been fully articulated
I guess Part B I see the solders that
there's the there's the ability for
people to generate the strawman version
of Christianity and then just feel
intelligent by comparing their own
knowledge to that and you know that's
pretty weak I would say I think Marxism
contributes to it a lot I mean I think
that the universities and our
intellectual life in general is still
saturated with Marxist Anil Marx's
presuppositions and I really think
that's a terrible thing I really don't
think that that's any better than having
our intellectual landscape populated by
neo-fascist ideas I don't see from a
historical perspective that there's any
reason whatsoever to assume that
neo-marxist ideas are any more morally
appropriate than neo-fascist ideas and I
think a lot of what drives them the
neo-marxist analysis of Christianity is
some of its some of its simplemindedness
I mean the Marxist tend to reduce
everything to power or to economics and
I mean power and economics are important
but to reduce everything to that is is
to reduce everything to any one thing is
a mark of a weak mind I mean most
problems are multivariate problems
they're not univariant problems I think
there's a hatred for the responsibility
that genuine Christianity lays upon a
person because at an archetypal level me
if you just if you just speak about this
psychologically the young said for
example the soul is naturally Christian
to hell of a thing to say but he had his
reasons for saying that and part of what
he was saying was that or what he
believed and Aldous Huxley talked about
this a bit too is that
there are elements of Christianity that
have taken conceptualization as far as
it can go and that's what makes it
archetypal so so I can give you an
example of that so there's a
presupposition in Christianity speaking
psychologically that human beings make
progress by making sacrifices that's a
good one you see this acted out to begin
to begin with to some degree in the Old
Testament where the sacrifices that
people make are are genuine archaic
sacrifices that they take something that
they're that they believe has value
perhaps a prized animal and burn it and
offer it to God and the reason that it's
burned as far as I've been able to tell
is because the archaic conception of the
world was that the world was a flat disc
and on top of that disc was a bowl and
the ball was the sky roughly speaking
and then outside the ball that's where
the gods existed and I think our gay
people believe that for the same reason
that we feel or when we look up in the
night sky we don't want to make the
mistake that just because people didn't
know some of the things we know now that
they were stupid they looked up at the
night sky or the day Steinfeld aw and
part of the intuition that came along
with that all was that while they were
looking at the night sky or the day star
they're looking into the infinite and
and that's allowed very tightly with
divinity so those those ideas going in
the background well if you burn
something and offer up to God the smoke
rises and God can detect the quality of
your sacrifice you might think well
that's again that's pretty simple minded
but it's not it's the dramatic
representation of an unbelievably
profound idea the profound idea is that
sometimes in order to make things go
properly you have to let go of something
that you deeply love or deeply want to
do and what it means what it means to
sacrifice is to let something go in the
present so that the
future can be better or to let something
go personally so that other people can
have it better and there's no difference
between the idea of sacrifice and the
discovery of the future as soon as you
discover the future one of the things
you realize is that you have to
sacrifice things in the present so that
the future manifests itself in a more
acceptable manner so then you think well
that's also an amazing discovery here's
the discovery human beings made if we
change our behavior in the present
better things could happen in the future
well no other animal really has ever
discovered them okay so that's very
tightly linked into the idea of
sacrifice so you might say well you have
to sacrifice something of value and so
sometimes I ask my students a lot of
them are second are children of
immigrants you know what did your
parents sacrifice so that you can go to
university and I mean everyone
understands that question the students
immediately tell me of you know the
things that their parents have done they
moved from some foreign country they
spent 18 hours a day working themselves
to their fingers to the bone at a
laundromat or a dry cleaner so that
their students could or so that their
children could have a richer and fuller
life they're sacrificing in the
sacrifice is based on it's based on
faith and the faith in it's essentially
a form of religious faith but we don't
have to get into that moment but the
fundamental driving idea is that the
reality is can be positively shaped by
sacrifice well that's amazing idea well
so then you might say well okay the
higher quality the sacrifice the more
profound the positive effect on the
future so reasonable proposition and so
then you might say what's the most
valuable possible sacrifice and now sure
that is well obviously yourself
so then you could say well that means
that the ultimate moral Junction the
ultimate moral injunction is to
sacrifice yourself in a manner that
makes the future better well that's the
central idea of Christianity the central
idea at the central figure mythological
figure at the core of Christianity is
the person who voluntarily sacrifices
themselves to the benevolent will of God
well if you have any sense you're
terrified at that idea and especially if
you're if you're I would say if you're a
rationalistic intellectual or
rationalizing intellectual mean who who
the hell wants to believe that that
that's your moral obligation is to
sacrifice yourself for the best well God
you don't know what that means I mean
the archetypal stories it means that you
end up crucified well
there's lots of reason to be not very
happy about that idea but and then you
say well is the fact that Chris Durant
Christianity is derided in the Academy a
good thing or a bad thing mostly it's a
terrible thing you know it's not like
Christianity can't use some criticism
although I think you know Nietzsche in
many ways Nietzsche took care of that
for us but mostly I think what we're
doing in the Academy is running as fast
as we can from the responsibility of
bearing our culture and revivifying it
and we are using any number of appalling
rationalizations and ideological
maneuvers to try to not only make them
acceptable personally but to proselytize
about it to others you know they're more
I wouldn't say cynical maybe I would the
more cynical part of me sometimes thinks
that the universities know do students
more harm than good especially on the
humanities in because they take students
at a very formative period of their life
when they're all when their belief
systems and their ability to identify
strongly with light are already somewhat
in question because they exist in a
culture that's been badly fractured and
they take those kids and they you know
they expose them to ideas that are
absolutely destructive and it's not
about happening against ideas like that
reading Nietzsche for example is or or
reading Dostoevsky I mean that can be a
very destructive act but the purpose of
Nietzsche's writing and Dusty's writing
is not to destroy it's to remove d'etre
so that something new can spring forth
and I just don't really see that
happening in the universities I think
they're too cynical and I think that
there's also a strong streak of serious
anti humanity among modern intellectuals
and that's been the case for at least a
hundred years you hear people say like
I think this was a statement from the
Club of Rome the people who are so
concerned about a population explosion
back in the mid 1960s that the world
would be better off if there were fewer
people on it or maybe that there were no
people on it well man you can't say
anything that's more appalling than that
you know if you said the planet would be
better off if there were fewer black
people on it it's like well no one's
going to put up with that or the planet
would be better off if there are fewer
European colonizers on it well you might
be able get away with that a little bit
more but probably not but as long as
your sentiments expend extend to
humanity as a whole it's perfectly
reasonable for you to say something like
that it that's the most horrific thing
you could possibly say I mean the kids
who go into high schools and shoot them
up call inviting kids not certainly what
they believe the planet would be a lot
better off if there were fewer people on
it maybe we'll take a few steps in that
direction so
Bob Smith says nice jacket thank you for
appreciate that all right
can you explain nature's general
philosophy and some of his most famous
ideas he's really hard to comprehend
Nietzsche's general philosophy I
probably can't do that I've been putting
together with my students here I've been
starting to plan a seminar on exist
dental ISM and and which would focus a
lot on Nietzsche and Dostoevsky
I think Nietzsche's so damn complicated
that you can't really do that I don't
think you can explain Nietzsche's
general philosophy first of all he
wasn't really a systematize or he he he
was skeptical of systematize it's very
difficult to distill someone who's not a
systematize err into you know a few
general principles and the thing is with
with us with some of the greatest
thinkers you actually have to read what
they wrote you have to read the original
writings because the the brilliance is
encapsulated in the original writings
and they can't be condensed so so let's
see can I do any better than that
can I explain H's general philosophy
truth serves life that's a good one and
I guess we could unpack that a little
bit I mean
that's a good example of exactly when
she is so staggeringly brilliant one of
the things he presumes when he makes a
statement like that is that a human
being is in an existential situation
that's characterized by the necessity of
determining what he or she will actually
accept as truth you know you might say
well truth is something you can prove
and that's how you know it's true but
unfortunately it's not that simple
because you have to decide what criteria
you're going to accept as proof and
there's an act of faith in that and and
there's Anna Naylor
the argument seems to be lacking and
this is the famous is aught conundrum
the David Hume described is okay well
let's say that you use science to lay
out a very detailed description of the
nature of the objective world well that
still doesn't mean that you know how to
act in that world and that's a big
problem it might be a fundamental
problem if the fundamental problem of
people isn't what is the nature of the
objective world but how is it that you
should conduct yourself while you're
alive well Nietzsche believed that the
fundamental question was how you should
conduct yourself while you're alive how
should you act and I would say that's
the fundamental question of meaning and
science can inform you but it can't
really solve that problem for you and
that's a problem and then science also
has this other terrible attribute some
sense which is that
because science can't solve the problem
of how you should act in the world it
empowers people towards the conclusion
that there is no answer to the question
how should you act in the world and so
that way that opens up a door to
nihilism and nihilism is is its
destructive it does not facilitate life
in fact it has the opposite effect
it takes the spirit out of people it
takes the motivation of people it makes
them bitter
it makes them resentful it makes them
hateful it's not a good thing
also Nietzsche is primarily concerned in
some sense without act and part of the
reason that he decomposes Christianity
to the degree that he does is because he
believed that Christianity was a very
very serious attempt to answer the
question how should you act and he also
believed that it had become fatally
flawed for a variety of reasons at least
in its typical socially socially
instantiated forms so he took it upon
himself to subject it to a criticism but
I've always thought of Nietzsche
it's a terrible image but I've always
thought niche as like a maggot in a
wound so what he's doing is clearing
away dead and diseased tissue so that
something else can live and it's a
terrible thing to watch it's a terrible
thing to apprehend and it's a hole it's
a terribly destructive thing to involve
yourself in because Nietzsche is he said
he philosophize with a hammer and that's
certainly true but he was trying to
clear the path for something new and
that something new he was trying to
formulate with his conception such as
like this neat the Superman
the next version of human being so to
speak and he thought of them as people
who would create their own values and
that would be the way forward out of the
wreckage of Christianity let's say I
think Nietzsche was wrong about that and
I say that with all due respect believe
me and I say it cautiously and I don't
think it's an original idea of my own
that Nietzsche was wrong and I think the
reason that he was wrong is because
people don't create values they discover
them or maybe they co-create them but
you can't create values by conjuring
them out of non-existence you could say
if you were scientifically minded that
values are in some sense arbitrary then
if you believe that values are arbitrary
you might then believe that people could
create them out of nothing but values
aren't arbitrary and most of the time
people discover them and maybe they
co-create them and one of the reasons
that I so have been so attracted to use
thinking is because Jung is in many ways
in Nietzschean a student of Nietzsche
also a student of Freud's but more
primarily a student of nature and use
lifelong endeavor was to understand what
the way forward might be given the
situation that needs to describe and the
situation that Nietzsche described in
some sense was that Christianity laid so
much emphasis on truth that it ended up
undermining its own axiomatic
presuppositions and so that you thought
following needs you well okay in
principle we have to create new values
but that's partly why you got so
interested in the unconscious because
one of the things he found particularly
in his analysis of the collective
unconscious that was that the values
that Nietzsche thought people should
create were actually lying dormant in
well in our imagination that's
the way of thinking about because that's
a good way of thinking about the
collective unconscious and that it was a
return to the deepest that the way
forward in terms of the generation of
new values was a return to the deepest
recesses of human existence and a
rediscovery of what was actually there I
touched on that a little bit today when
I was talking about the necessity for
sacrifice like there's an archetypal
idea that the Savior the Messiah is is
by definition the person who is willing
to sacrifice him or herself for the
ultimate good whatever that happens to
be and that that's the appropriate
pathway forward well that's that's an
artifact of Christianity and I think
that you almost right I think he's
correct that's a terrible thing to say
because I mean unis such a radical
thinker that is it's it's funny because
he only is subject to a lot of criticism
I mean I read Richard Noel's book on
Nietzsche I think it was called the
Arian Christ and know basically who I
think was a very is or was a very
resentful person um I think he did a
hatchet job on you he the cover of his
book made you look like it was a Nazi I
mean how what a cheap shot that is but
you know he accused you know basically
fomenting a cult and I read Noel's book
and it just made me laugh because what
you is actually up to is so much worse
so to speak then merely starting a cult
it's like accusing an axe murder of
annoying annoying his pet cat you know
it's that the difference is that
extensive the sorts of things that um
was actually messing around with are so
complicated and terrible compared to
just building a little cult that you
know it's absolutely clear that Noah had
no idea what he was talking about unison
like Nietzsche like Dostoevsky is a
terrifying person and I think part of
the reason that Jung is not well
regarded in the Academy and also my
Christianity is subject to such
continual rationalist and criticism is
because people open up you and take one
look at what he's doing and either just
don't get it at all or they get a little
bit of it it scares them so bad if you
think there's no damn way I'm going
there and and cuz I can really
understand that I think think anybody
with any sense would be very very
careful about trying to figure out what
you was talking about
is cognitive behavior of mussoorie here
I missed that sorry about that it's a
good idea to believe in something
healthy delusions like karma or life
after death that's a knee wall socket
well there is a whole line of social
psychology that was very popular about
15 years ago in fact the most cited
social psychological paper ever written
was about the necessity of positive
illusions you know the basic hypothesis
was life was so tragic and dismal that
unless you bolstered yourself against it
with you know defensible optimism I
suppose if you were being charitable or
just positive illusions lies is what I
think they are that life would actually
be intolerable and I think that's an
unbelievably nihilistic and vicious
philosophy I think the fact that that
was actually seriously put forward by by
a generation of social psychologists as
a medication for the modern disease of
meaning it was an out is an absolute
indictment of the entire field no
there's nothing about illusions that are
healthy but that doesn't mean that
cynicism and despair are forms of truth
or that nihilism is a form of truth
there's no such thing as healthy
delusions
now you know any wall socket says like
karma well I don't know if karma is a
healthy delusion and I'm not so sure
about I mean there's some elements of
karma that I think are extremely
interesting from a psychological
perspective I'm going to scrap the
reincarnation element of it because well
for obviously at least for the sake of
simplicity but I believe in karma I
think that no one gets away with
anything ever I think every single thing
you do that is immoral because the moral
thing is an attempt to work the
structure of reality everything you do
that's immoral comes back to haunt you
and it generally comes back in
multiplying form now that doesn't mean
you'll be able to draw the cause of
connections like you might have done
something immoral who knows five years
ago and that produced like a crack in
the structure of your being and like
it's five years later and all sorts of
things are falling into that crack and
you have no idea that that initial act
was what produced this you know
cascading consequence of events but that
doesn't mean it didn't so what did Camus
mean by revolt in the myth of Sisyphus
what are some ways to revolt without
being destructive or should one simply
be a good end thank you
well that's 19km edge well the first
thing I should say about is it's not
those so simple to be a good end like I
think being a good at is better than
just being a chaotic and useless and and
so you should probably go from chaotic
and useless and to good and that's a
process of maturation that's what
happens when you're you know you move
from being a child to an adolescent to a
young adult you adopt the strictures and
responsibilities of your culture to
discipline yourself now if you stop at
the point where you're a good aunt well
then I think you know that's not so good
then then you're you're an avatar of the
pathologies of your call
as well as an avatar of the virtues of
your culture so but you you it's
fighting against Meereen culturation is
that's that's not virtue that's failure
that's just failure to mature you know
that was actually one of Nietzsche's
questions of conscience are you leading
or are you just running away well the
answer that almost always is you're
running away you might think you're
leaving but the probability that you're
leading especially if you haven't
seriously considered the possibility
that you're running away is like really
what's the point of chances if you if
you really think about snot that easy
lead and is pretty easy to run away so
if you're not doing what other people
are doing you're probably running away
and you might say well that's pretty
rough it's like fair enough you know if
you've got some absolutely unique
destiny that you have to manifest more
power to you
but most of the time what I see are
people who think they have a unique
destiny and really what they're doing is
wandering off the beat bash into some
thorn ring ditch where things are not
going to be good for them so what are
some ways to revolt without being
destructive revolt against what that be
the question I mean Severus
you could try revolting against your
lack of discipline like that's good
that's a war that's a war if you want a
war
maybe you do because people need war you
know I think it was William James who
said that people need a moral equivalent
to war I think that's what you was
trying to discover by the way the moral
equivalent to war and I think he did
discover it as well and that's tied up
with the idea of sacrifice if you want
to revoke you should revolt against your
own pathology and inadequacy and
uselessness and resentment and cruelty
and blindness and yeah you could have
war against that you could revolt
against out that give you something to
do
p-professor MRA people are often quite
smart why do they have this strong
tendency towards atheism oh well you
know people who have smart get atheistic
right away because you know it's obvious
you really believe in God you believe in
an old man in the sky you really think
the world's only seven thousand years
old it's like you really believe Christ
turned wine into water you know no one
who wasn't foolish would believe that
well that's the statement of someone
who's I guess who's smart enough to
start to notice something about what
people believe but you know they're ten
steps along up fifty thousand mile
journey so and then the other thing I
already mentioned this about atheism
people like to think that the reason
they're atheistic is because they're
clear-headed and rational it's like well
first of all no probably they're not
because how often you meet someone who's
clear-headed and rational
I don't being psycho analytically minded
I'm always way more likely to look for
the dark reason that someone is doing
something rather than the light reason
you know the reason that's moving them
towards the light because it's hard to
move towards the light and so I would
say most of the time people are
atheistic well it's kind of its
fashionable in some cynic it's a
fashionable way to be able to revolt if
you're rational and if you're kind of an
intellectual but also you can just
dispense with responsibility if you're
atheistic and I think that's ninety
percent of the reason
that's especially in modern world that's
why people are proponents of atheism you
know where they have some particular
hatred for the church
I think Richard Dawkins has a particular
I would I would I've thought of this
many times I would swear that something
happened to him when he was a kid that
wasn't good and that the church was
involved because he has such an animus
against the church it's that it it
possesses him there's a reason for that
all right so let's see here
can you explain why the conventional
wisdom about ancient people are swords
with your ideas about each and people
yeah that's Harold boom I can explain
that people like to think they're smart
and they like and the easiest way to
think you're smart in many ways is to
think that other people aren't and so we
think well the people who came before us
all these thousands of centuries you
know they just didn't know what we knew
well their cultures didn't have the same
degree of staggering technological
capacity that ours did but that didn't
mean that they were stupid I mean throw
the average person back into ancient
Athens they're not gonna last very long
lack of respect and you know that is a
definite hallmark of modern culture is
that you can hardly even tell you know
you cannot even say well being
respectful it sounds like you're from
1890 be respectful well
if you're not if you don't want to be
nihilistic you better be respectful
because being nihilistic and having
respect for nothing are exactly the same
thing so you can start by having some
respect for your ancestors and try to
figure out what the hell they were
talking about you read the Old Testament
for examples a very weird book it's a
very very very very weird book lots of
people wrote it
lots of people added in it it got
sequence together and turned into this
volume for reasons that we just can't
understand it's a collective work of the
human imagination and people read it so
simple in such a simple-minded way they
read it like fundamentalist like
simple-minded fundamentalist Protestants
think about science no the
fundamentalist Protestants think the
Bible is literally true science is
literally true
thus the Bible is science well you know
no the people who wrote the Bible work
scientists that's just not how it works
but then this that the modern critics of
of religious thinking of traditional
religious thinking they're just they're
the same they do the same thing except
backwards they say no no religion was
science it's just bad science and so you
know we don't have to pay attention to
it well it's not science it's something
else
it's ethics it's morality it's drama
it's all of that and drown us about how
to live and religious drama is it's a
definitional issue there is nothing
deeper than religious drama and the
reason for that is that depth defines
what's religious and like I know this
firsthand partly because in my clinical
practice like I often see people who are
terrible terrible terrible trouble and
often that trouble is ethical and if the
trouble they're in is bad enough there's
no other language to conceptualize it in
that isn't religious because the
religious language comes into its own
when you're dealing with problem
normally have life and death but
literally of heaven and hell and you
know modern people think well there's no
such thing as heaven and there's no such
thing as hell it's like okay fine
there's no such thing as heaven let's
accept that but if you think there's no
such that you've held it's like
I can't see how someone who's educated
would ever dare to make that claim like
after everything that happened to us in
the 20th century I can't see that
someone could ever say that there's no
such thing as hell without being
terrified that a bolt of lightning would
obliterate them on the spot
you know hell is real and if you want to
talk about use religious language and if
you want to figure out how to get away
from Hell you use religious language and
that's what religious language is for so
you know the that that's actually
understandable now I would say if if you
want to learn about this you can you can
read Nietzsche you can read Dostoyevsky
you can read you it's hard you can read
you student Eric Norman Eric Norman was
a genius like a lot of this information
is there waiting for people to to begin
to understand it but it's hard slog
again and part of the problem is is that
you get to hell way before you get to
heaven you know and one of the things
young is sometimes conceptualized as a
New Age thinker and I think that's
absurd I think it's it's completely
absurd
one of those fundamental propositions is
that if you follow a meaningful and
truthful path that will take you to the
worst place you can imagine and then
possibly having gone there the journey
uphill you know towards the light can
begin in earnest well
who wants that well no one if they have
any sense but you know you also made
another statement which was really cut
me in the bone when I first understood
it he said anything you don't thoroughly
understand you act out in the world as
fate and so one of the one of the
lessons I took away from that is then
you know if you don't want Hell to
manifest itself in the world then you
better understand your role in producing
it and I would say that's actually the
primary religious injunction and I would
also say that that's a big part of the
reason why belief systems such as
Christianity I'm talking mostly about
Christianity because that's what I'm
most familiar with but and also because
it's it's definitely out the be
nobleness the foundation of Western
civilization actually quite a fan of
Western civilization I mean the
fundamental moral injunction is in
Christianity one of them I mean they're
all tangled together against to some
degree is like you want to constrain
hell within yourself
well that's no joke man I mean
you know one of what another thing I
learned from helium for me chip was that
if you if you if you look at the sorts
of things that happen say in Nazi
Germany or in the Soviet Union or in
Mao's China or that are still happening
around the world where there's
systematic torture and persecution of
millions and billions of people where
where the entire state was devoted
towards making things as bad as they can
possibly be and then making them even
worse after that that people played a
role in that and they were people like
you and that means that people like you
play a role in that and so then the
question is what's your role and is that
the game that you want to be playing
well that's a serious question because
it is people like you who were
responsible for that and it means that
to the degree that you're a person and
you don't want that to happen anymore
you have to sort that out within
yourself so I can take and explain and I
think I'll close with this another
deeply religious idea there's another
idea this is an archetypal idea about
the image of the savior of the Messiah
the Messiah is the person who takes the
sins of the world unto himself that's a
classic archetypal ideas like what does
that mean
it means that you look for the
motivations that drove Hitler in
yourself because they are there and
that's what it means to take the sins of
the world onto yourself it means that
you have to view yourself as the
perpetrator of archetypal evil you know
one of the things you said for example
was that if you take a small moral
failing that a person manifests and you
digging into that as deeply as you can
you end up in the center of Health like
the roots of that unethical behavior go
all the way down to the to the to the
archetype and in my experience that's
being true that's that's right that's
why people want to have conversations
about this sort of thing you see it
happening in in intimate relationships
all the time where there are things that
the two people who are involved in the
relationship will just not talk about it
why because they don't want to go there
and where is it that they don't want to
go they don't want to get to the bottom
of things
well you'll wonder because you know
that's an archetypal idea to hell is a
pit it's at the bottom of things it's
like yeah that is where it is and you
have to go there if you want to
straighten things out it's like who the
hell wants to do that well the
alternative is that it plays itself out
in the world and we've seen that and
that doesn't look like a good idea to me
so well I guess we should probably end
there because I'm getting fuzzy minded
that's always a good time to stop so
thank you very much for tuning in and if
this seems to have been successful kinda
out of slow start as far as I'm
concerned that's kind of muddle-headed
to begin with but you know maybe we'll
live it all that out anyways I'm
thinking about doing this on a regular
basis so you know let me know what you
think and and we'll see how many people
watch it and we'll see what happens and
like thanks to all my Ras and their lots
of research assistants here already
helping male with this so mastering the
technology and figuring out what to do
with YouTube so thank you very much for
tuning in and hopefully I'll see you
again
ciao